[Music]
how's everyone doing good I know you
guys just went through this but how does
it feel being on the other side I hope
they're not salty yeah they will be you
think they're going to be salty yeah
[Music]
yes
I think style I think Moon Shoes should
go first
Moon I mean it's just the tattoos and
the freckles like I'm a big tattoo guy
so okay that's fair enough your first I
would say green first she's more of my
type physically I would say what are you
going to be looking for physically in
the women uh personally for me uh
Height's a big thing so I probably look
someone that's tall sort of athletic
looking usually same race as me black or
mixed someone with good style a good
face I'm a big face guy like I don't
really care what your body looks like
got pretty smile cute nose good eyes
that would be good for me someone who's
not short cuz I don't know it's kind of
weird if you're tall and you like
someone who's kind of short it's kind of
weird I do tend to prefer like a girl
next door kind of vibe I don't say I
have a type but a lot of people say I
have a type what is it uh they say curly
hair um big boobs what about you who's
your one um I think Jean dress would be
my number one um I like the girl next
door Vibe jean dress is I'm one too all
right she's tall she has a lot I I don't
know I just this what I like yeah I
think we should put her one and we put
Gan dress to all right go go go keep
going keep going go there we go perfect
I said it to you flip flop she should
move up why do you think I think she
just she has like she has like a really
nice body it looks like interesting
everyone's beautiful it's kind really
yeah where do you think the men will
place you um honestly I think I will be
somewhere around a little bit above mid
because because this is how I would rank
myself I think she's wearing the only
cool
skirt and it's more cohesive from dock
to top it matches a little better uhhuh
than the rest of these outfits going on
there's some interesting choices being
made so we have to move Miss blonde to
miss blonde got to move up I think
yeah one more there we go and then I
think bubble Miss bub bubbles has to go
up bubblegum Tob
so
and then YouTu and then switch flipflop
there we go I'm not mad at this where do
you think you might wind up in
line probably on the lower half not
because I don't think I'm beautiful I
just think that there is a specific
standard of beauty right now and I don't
necessarily fit all of the I don't check
off all of the boxes for most races Mo
this has to move down a little
[Music]
bit I think moves down to three three
all right we could do
that I'm good with this lineup this yeah
yeah yeah what was going through your
mind when you had your headphones on and
you were getting judged um I honestly
was in another planet I was just like
vibing by myself I was not staring at
them and I was kind of just not really
caring because I really don't care what
they think
you're all right yeah I just got in from
a run training for a marathon sucks
training for a marathon in the middle of
the workday that's something are you
thirsty I'm parched well first things
first we want to thank liquid IV for
sponsoring this episode liquid IV's
hydration multiplier is an electrolite
drink mix that tastes amazing and is
perfect for staying hydrated with their
new lemon lime sugar-free hydration
multiplier you get faster hydration than
water alone and it has three times the
electrolytes of the leading sports drink
yeah that's great can I get my drink now
I'm just making sure you know what
you're getting first in each packet you
get eight vitamins and nutrients for
everyday wellness and 100% daily value
of essential B vitamins B3 B5 B6 B12 so
what do you think I need to get my hands
on more of this stuff like now please
please can I have some well you're in
luck because you can use code Jubilee or
click the link in the description to get
20% off plus free shipping on your next
order thank you to liquid IV for
sponsoring today's video now let's get
back to the
episode do you guys do you guys drive
yeah you drive yes yes cool what is your
one red flag and one beige flag it's I
don't think it's a red flag but guys
usually do I do musical theater what no
that's sick that's sick that's what I've
literally never had that reaction so
positively what's a beige flag beige is
like kind of your neutral oh some people
like this some people don't like this
what would your exes say my exes would
say maybe I'm a bit like I'm like a
little bit bossy sometimes for like
traveling or stuff like that like I'll
be the one planning stuff okay hi um I'm
Victoria and my red flag okay um I think
it's my expectation I expect a lot from
everyone um I don't know if I can meet
my own standard sometimes so maybe um
it's really hard to impress me um a
beige flog is I don't like to party I
don't like to party um I don't like
people I like to stay home I like to
read books and I like to drink tea love
tea I mean I drank tea this morning I
read a book this morning is all I did
I'm Jordan I think a red flag for me
some people are very bothered because I
say bagle no way are you Canadian yes I
am oh my God like school bag oh God
where in Canada are you from Toronto
um I was born in Toronto um beige
flag people either like or really
dislike that I have tattoos makes sense
actually that makes sense that makes
sense that's really red flag I would say
that um I have a hard time to
communicate about feelings sometimes so
that's definitely a red flag beige flag
I was going to say the same thing that
I'm not really a party person um I might
look like it but I'm I like to stay at
home I guess my red flag would be I
think I have a strong personality and
I'm like not afraid to say how I feel
maybe that's a beige is that a beige
that can be a beige that be a
beige a red flag is I like to go out I
like to go outside beige flag kind kind
fall in the beige flag a red flag I talk
a lot I like to talk I talk a lot still
in the beige
category um do you usually have a type
funny um likes animals cuz I like I have
two dogs as long as they're confident if
they're all shy and stuff I'm going to
be like oh people who are smart kind
funny if I can't crack a joke with you
if thought you getting offend it how how
we going to have fun uh they have to be
funny or at least like unfunny enough to
like think I'm funny cuz I you know if
if I can Whittle them down and be like
oh God he's so funny it's actually I've
just tricked you into thinking I'm funny
that I think that would be good uh how
much money is in your guys' savings
account right
now heyo what the no comment no comment
I like to shop I do so if that tells you
anything say a little bit more than um
half a million
cool not
that but I don't know I don't really
want to share I love it yeah I'm good
I'm I'm good
yeah would our attractiveness be defined
by money no no not at all it's just like
kind of gotta question like do you save
for the future yeah it's just like
a Mercedes can you like tell us what you
do to got like such a big Bank uh I work
in social media oh like an influencer
yeah okay that's cool thank you what
food do you hate like what what do you
like God I can't eat that Pi pickles
all Seafood even like sushi yeah I know
I thought they going to ask more like
deeper questions just to get to know me
as a person it was just like dry like do
you feel like you guys asked enough
questions to get to know the women God
no not at all I think our questions were
terrible yeah we did Miss really obvious
ones like oh where are you guys from how
old are you what are you do for work
don't know why those didn't pop in our
heads but they didn't at the time but
yeah what's the craziest thing you've
done to an
ex huh like what's the craziest thing
you've done to an
ex Facebook so F this was in high school
though but he was talking to another
girl and like oh this sounds so bad
now there was a hat that I had of his
and I think his grandmother like gifted
it she passed away and when he did
whatever he did I burnt the Hat because
I was just like oh that's not bad that's
not bad okay okay okay beige beige
grandma that is
red um I made a fake social media
account and I pretended to be a girl
just to like try to pick him up and he
failed the test and then I cut his tires
oh did you cut three all of them D cut
three okay that's fire I'm on good terms
with both exes that I have so I guess
nothing no contact the worst thing I did
was block and Report well why report
well um was enough just I don't want to
see you I don't want to see friends that
you have I don't want to see any remnant
of you um I'm also friends with both my
exes yeah I don't have any bad blood
towards them and vice versa and yeah you
guys got any questions there I have zero
I have no questions that's come on man I
have a this is like my one flaw I when
it comes to these things I don't have
questions to ask like I don't play Truth
or Dare for that specific reason cuz I
can't think of a truth or a dare okay
what do you think is the strangest thing
that turns you
on bid I think when when men are just
backing up with the car and they kind of
put the head over them that's yeah
that's like I don't know why it's hot
smooth yeah really kind men like it's
just like just people who are just kind
for no reason like there was no reason
for you to do this thing for this person
you don't know cuz I know like some
people are like bad boys are like the
like people are very very sweet I like
socially aware I like it when you move
out of the grocery um aisle and you just
know when people are around you and
you're just you're aware I like gamer
boys oh like what's your favorite game
Legend of Zelda is my favorite game of
all time I'm a nerd I like when I make
someone laugh really really hard like I
just like if you laugh really hard at
something I said yeah I don't know valid
valid what's your favorite thing about
yourself I think my boobs I really like
my boobs I was going to say it could be
physical or personality wise or both but
it could be any of that but boobs with a
sense of humor I think that's a great
combination nice I think I'm like really
loyal to my friends so like I feel like
I'm like a rider I love my answer and
your like
you I really like my mole it's right in
the middle in between my eyebrows I know
everyone's looking at it and I love it
it's right in the middle and it's very
lucky that's all um I really like my
eyes
okay I like my face and I think I'm
funny so well everybody think I'm funny
[Music]
uh I put her there because I feel like
we have a lot of like things in common
um I just thought she was really
attractive I'm not going to lie she
seemed really fun to like be around and
stuff she kind of scared me I'm not
going to lie I feel like she would like
beat me up and then uh it was just
didn't have really much in common uh I
feel like if we were to hang out we
would just kind of sit there in silence
uh I really like this person's hair a
lot and also their outfit I'm a fan of
also hair color although not so much in
the Footwear department but you know um
and then we would have opposite things
be funny to each other so that would be
like fun to be around of like trying to
get someone who doesn't think you're
funny to laugh she was pretty but kind
of not my type and um not really my type
at all number one I think I'm the most
sort of physically attracted to and also
she was kind of quirky and I kind of
like that quirkiness number two I think
she just has a lot of green flags and
seemed like a wonderful person number
four I thought was beautiful but you
know perhaps I don't know if we would
vibe and then number five we would be
like you know very good friends but just
I don't think there was like a lot of
physical attraction so my first
selection like I don't know her her
sense of energy Lin with mind just to
hire for greater knowledge uh number
three for me too it's just the swag the
style shoe gang on
point uh number one cuz uh physically
and I think now getting to know them
this would definitely be someone I would
go for in public four and five same like
I'd probably just be friends with these
people like nothing crazy or serious
just like they seem like we would get
along in some sort of way but like they
wouldn't be like someone I'd go for
[Music]
oh hi just hop again to see if you're
liking this episode of Ray gang if you
are like And subscribe for
more how we feeling ladies I think I'm
going to stay right here honestly I feel
like I'll shift down a little bit me too
same what do you think would make you
shift down I don't know I feel like the
questions weren't but I don't think
there were enough to get to know us
separate from like our physical
attributes actually let's be positive
we're going to we're going to
we're only moving up this is very
depressing we're staying where we are
moving up so in fth we have
Mercedes this way what what what the
boobs were not working that
much with 11 points in fourth
Victoria with 13 points third we have
zenab with 15 points
points okay in second Jordan 17
points and in first Charlie with 19
points slay that's crazy do you guys
have anything to say for yourselves I
think we all have very different types
both physically and Vibe wise so it's
just that makes sense way different than
what I thought was going to do you girls
have any thoughts about the final order
of this line I mean I'm kind of shocked
did not think they were vibing with me
at all so I don't know how this happened
what do you think maybe put you at the
top I have no idea like I don't know
anyone else I think I'm just too rich
for these guys yo I'm sorry okay that's
true okay yeah I mean you know what
we're all different I can't be for
everyone and that's that's
okay for the the men's final order I was
shocked what were you shocked by I was
like although we all belong in number
one I feel like they don't really have
taste I'm not putting any girls girls
down but I I definitely think it
reflected um how much they could handle
um a really bad I think men tend
to think on a very physical level or
think about women in relation to how it
works for them like what's a crazy King
what's the crazy thing you've done to
your ex like just for them to mentally
prepare for what they're going to get
into without figuring out what you are
as a person or who you are it's just
like what's the worst thing you're going
to do to me if I date you or like yeah I
think men getting secure when I talk
about my finances and they see that I'm
a little bit further than they are so
I'm not taking any offense here I'm not
upset about it I was kind of expecting
that that's what happened to me like
personally as a personal experience